il a été retrouvé noyé dans la vologne
une rivière des vosges il avait les
poignets liés et une cordelette autour
du cou le petit grégory quatre ans a été
assassiné et le meurtrier a téléphoné à
la famille après avoir accompli son
geste horrible france à chanter c'est
dans cette rivière qu'on a retrouvé le
corps du petit grégory 4 ans qui est et
mains liées mardi après midi
l'enfant jouait dans la maison de ses
parents à l'autre bout du village
au même moment sont donc le reçois un
coup de téléphone anonyme
une voix inconnue lui dis je me suis
vengé j'ai pris l'enfant
c'est vrai grégory a disparu les
gendarmes organisent une battue après
trois heures de recherches
on retrouve son corps dans la rivière
depuis quelques temps la famille étaient
harcelés ou menacés par des inconnus au
téléphone elle avait eu des coups de
téléphone anonymes d'edel être pareil
anonyme et puis il y avait une personne
je ne sais pas qui a exactement tout est
venu défense et ça pour gagner des
choses comme ça quoi elle avait toujours
des menaces kwapis sans plus ces
derniers temps il y avait encore eu du
cheval il a toujours eu quand même plus
ou moins il y en a toujours
la piste poursuivi par les enquêteurs
celle d'un règlement de compte familial
les policiers ont déjà procédé à
l'audition d'une dizaine de personne
ment ou proches de la famille
ils sont persuadés que le cargo
connaissait très bien grégory